[Music]
what's going on there reject nation
thanks so much for clicking on this
video hey hit that like button to give
yourself some credit just for clicking
on this video and also we're gonna watch
kingdom episode three of season one
today so subscribe click the
notification bell to get notified when
our next reaction rare kingdom is up we
put these up weekly and as always full
length watch alongs we stick with the
top coat or over at our patreon page
cover a whole bunch of shows over there
as well we're at the same tier you get
the option for reaction highlights and
watch alongs included prepper thank you
boss for editing this down let's watch
kingdom today
oh
great gaga
oh you're goner man
you're not helping man
hey oh boy
it just doesn't stop
really to kill him
oh
man poor
poor schmuck oh man that uh that's a
terrible situation
did it work
nurse badass
okay so you can get them in the throat
that's good to know
now use the sword and shabby jab jab
oh man oh god
oh
[Music]
just ride it out till the sun comes up
yeah use the sword and stab me step
nice
this guy man
oh no no no she dead
oh no baby on back
just when you thought they weren't gonna
do it just throw the baby
no
poor baby
toss it like a football
oh
so real
that's how my family was when we had to
share a large plate of fries
oh no they come from zombie river
holy [ __ ]
oh
ah
[Applause]
i like a nice slow start to a show yeah
nice little build
[Music]
[Applause]
my man come on headshot headshot my man
oh my god this guy is so much cooler
just don't drink anything from here on
no don't put your hand near his mouth
[Music]
wow these are the best background
performers i've ever seen in my entire
life
jesus christ
let's go back to the politics
i
get rid of them oh christ guys
oh yes
fire your arrows that way
[Laughter]
holy god
okay so they can't swim that's helpful
at least
oh my god
i hope you're happy
and what a nation all this is yours
what's your plan to get rid of all the
zombies
now start step step stabbing
stab me
wow she's way more pregnant
i want to like just go into the show
just tell them to start stabbing them
eddie try to warn you
sorry
[Laughter]
what's
that's right
[Music]
oh my god he's becoming a real goddamn
leader
people are gonna want you to be king
yeah they won't accept that stupid ugly
baby yeah you're gonna have to fight
that baby yeah
stab that baby right on the jugular
oh my gosh you're the ace in the hole
it's gonna be andrew lincoln
it's damn or
[Laughter]
uh
[Music]
you know i am in a lot of pain
trying to pee this whole reaction
ah crap no
[Music]
oh
so they can be dead and you can infect
them seems to still come back
[Music]
[Music]
oh go to hell
they should pull themselves up by their
bootstraps come on
remember that pig
you know i don't know
maybe can transmit the disease
chlamydia ah damn it
let me do mine
i got the clap people snap crackle and
pop that was one hell of an episode
people
really really enjoyed that one the first
like 20 25 minutes was just so bleak
stark
and uh
as aggressive and harsh as it was it was
also
so well staged my god like the amount
of choreography that goes into putting
one of those openings sequence not even
opening scene it's just the first half
of the episode putting putting all that
together is so difficult to manage and i
love how
it's you really feel the background
players
putting them to work oh my god
tell me about it
i mean the amount of extras that you
have who have to do this specialized
physicality plus get makeup plus then
have to perform
and wardrobe yeah like all that wardrobe
heavy wardrobe yeah yeah yeah run around
don't trip and and yeah and then horde
up on each other like i would i would be
fascinated to see some kind of kingdom
zombie behind the scenes feature because
like they've made so much about that in
like the walking dead about like wow we
got our zombie school and stuff there's
like some really cool zombie performing
on that show but this is like a next
level of intensity especially with how
much they make them pile up on each
other and stuff like that well they're
lead actors too though i love how the
way they frame it of how close proximity
because you got to keep the the timing
of the running down is so hard to keep
up with especially when you have like
your your main characters like the crown
prince like muy young
where they're running away together and
then you have like some of the zombies
like right behind them today all that
all like the timing on everything with
the amount of tracking and like just
moving following shots that you have
throughout
it was just so well done and equally
desolate and harrowing
simultaneously it was beautiful
and
shitty at the same time yeah and it's
funny because you blurted something out
midway through the first chunk of the
episode you're like i want to go back to
the politics now and i actually really
appreciated
just how long all that went down because
the previous two the first two episodes
have a structure where there is some
zombie stuff toward the beginning but it
feels like most of the first halves of
those were about the context and the
politics and then we kind of go into
night time whereas this was like you
feel just how interminably long a night
can feel when you just want it to end
and you just want salvation well i love
how
they slowly let you see how a lot of
this works
like this i look like the setup of the
the way a lot of the fighting was going
down like when they had
the guys in the prison when they're i
don't know what that's called those
boards like stocks almost like like dual
stocks yeah the way that was going down
and the way they handled the uh because
i'm someone who can get distracted i
just talk about this in a different show
recently about
when when someone's having a distorted
vision and then they like strapped into
a gopro and they're like oh everything
looks weird but that was a very
effective use of when you put them on
the board there you're watching them
fight with each other and it's great
motivation you could one character says
he's exhausted he could feel the
exhaustion just running through them and
and just the
undeniable desperation as this is all
um
as is all uh presenting itself but then
when the sun came up it was
it was so
i don't know man it's i i keep wanting
to say it's cool like as as
uncomfortable and unsettling it is i
can't help but admire how cool it is too
like when they all are just start
scrambling and piling into like dark
corners and to the point where you're
like [ __ ] it must be hard to find some
of them when the sun's out yeah yeah and
they like really go for it like the most
light restricted places possible they
pack themselves in and it is cool
because it's it's like an animal hiding
yeah absolutely and it takes you know
there are familiar aspects of zombie
lore that will always kind of track
across various stories but i think
that's one more unique aspect of this is
how animal they are especially when it
comes time to avoid the light and go
hibernate for the daytime yeah and and
that does give i think with
with good horror
a lot of the time what you what you
really need is a sense that the
protagonists have a fighting chance
otherwise it
just feels like pointless yeah
so
to with this
you know i actually really like the
implementation of having the
the the the the zombies as you said
hibernate during during the day uh
because it gives because then it gives a
good ticking clock
to okay it's just uh wait till the sun
comes
makes you hyper aware of the time yeah
yeah yeah if i was like a calm during
the day but really uncomfortable once
the night comes up and i think that's a
really i just think it's super neat man
i i have
i have a weird weird feeling five pound
i'm not i can't be alone in that i
imagine a lot of you guys are also like
no it's awesome yeah it is
like it's it's a i feel like some of the
best horror leaves you feeling both
where you're like oh god this is so
relentlessly unsettling but also this is
so engrossingly interesting and cool
yeah yeah it felt like storyboarded like
it's just so staged it was it was like
quality filmmaking like when they're
trying to get over the wall
and they're climbing and the way they do
the reveal shots like that that one wide
shot and they're like get off the wall
you see there's like other people who
are just attached to the wall like like
spiders it's just waiting to crawl up
there you know that was that was awesome
i i i'm so impressed with this show and
it just really shocks me that i've only
recently heard about this series from
recommendations from you guys and not
having just heard it from word of mouth
myself because this is one of the most
impressive things i've ever seen on
netflix abs oh absolutely yeah yeah i
mean they're so good at portraying
different kinds of desperation and two i
mean i love the way that they
continue to kind of poke at and
deconstruct especially just they i mean
you know their various systems of
society but especially class systems
with you know these guys we keep the
magistrate and the other guy who's
always in the white silks uh who is
always like you know oh you you know
you're not allowed in here because uh
you're the peasants and what not and
this is zarya yes yeah yeah okay i want
to call him the seabird but we'll get to
monetize and uh yeah
and i i don't know i i find that's not
you know a new thing for this show it's
it's you know a part of a lot of great
zombie fiction but it's that thing where
you're looking around and you're like
you're you're adhering and you're and
you're holding up this system that you
feel
very you probably makes you feel safe
but if you look around you've got to
realize that it's not
yeah it's not the world you live in
anymore well i really like the
discussion or the debate that occurred
from what they should do with the bodies
like really what would they do in in
this time period
how would they handle this because they
want to be respectable to the dead and
they got a lot of culture and
hierarchy ethics that you got to be
obedient to
and like these standards you got to
abide by but
uh so so i really loved when they were
like no some of them have to just be
buried you can't just burn these bodies
but what they're doing with the prince
you can you really really start to click
with me what they're doing here at least
this is kind of the impression that i'm
getting
is that everyone who who's um you know
involved as like a political figure
is so separate and distant from the
people they're not connected to them
and uh that juxtaposition is really
shown that distance whereas the prince
when he gets involved he seems like he's
in it with the people
so
it's like he's the kind of
person who's you know
at least championing to be on the throne
and you can see he's really caring
sympathetic like he's heartbroken over
the death of his father
he doesn't really talk about i want to
be king you know yeah
um
but he also seems like one who could
inspire and lead because he be involved
with the people like he's a kind of
person who could be a leader that people
want to follow he doesn't just have the
title yeah and i i loved how this
episode seemed to really represent that
like literally like kind of with some of
the cinematography i couldn't tell if it
was intentional or not just because it's
daytime it seemed like they were like
the the shining
prince
light what's the term i'm looking for
goddammit god light or halo light when
he like holds his sword down there's
like the way the light's shining upon
him as he's fighting saying it for the
people saying you killed a lot of
innocent people died like he really
seemed like pissed off and hurt by that
yeah there's like a righteous
indignation
knight in shining armor
i don't know what i'm going back i don't
know it's backlit it was cool it's
awesome and then you even got more
scenes here with moo young where he's
always been kind of laughable and then
here you're like oh man you're actually
like a real badass i didn't think your
package in terms of being your psychic
did not think you were actually that
capable of whooping that much ass
that probably surprised me the most in
this episode was damn look at him with
that bow and arrow yeah
yeah
it's very gratifying and and two i mean
you know there's certain developments i
like that
you know in the background of all of
this we got a little bit of uh uh update
on like okay this wasn't like the case
with the one of the original you know uh
when the emperor bit the kid he just
died and now this uh whatever's causing
this is mutating and it's causing people
to actually get up and and you know go
eat the flight i feel like we saw at
least one other person in this episode
who looked like they were afflicted with
whatever this disease is and uh and and
they just died as well yeah so i i
wonder
if more is gonna become of that if it's
going to mutate and expand more because
you know there's two seasons at least so
i can't imagine this season becomes
resident evil monsters yeah yeah is it
gonna spread to other creatures even i
don't know like you you asked about that
pig and i'm like what's the significance
of the pig you know you sure are drawing
attention to that pit because yeah and i
mean pigs as far as the animal kingdom
goes if i'm not mistaken have uh you
know in terms of bacteria and diseases
are they're pretty communicable between
you know humans and pigs and whatnot so
are they
uh i feel like pigs are again correct me
if i'm wrong but they're said to be one
of the closer genetic relations that is
susceptible to a lot of things we're
susceptible to i would love this video
to get 300 comments and it's all correct
it's all about how wrong i was about
like man a lot of people know a lot
about pigs in the comments things could
be more different john
you have a better chance of catching
something from a horse
and then they had the character uh
chubby on pal i remember that i don't
have imdb pulled up in front of me right
now well done or is it pie
you say anything a little better like
house of pies show bi it's it's an
alright
sometimes on imdb there's an l yes i
believe so i can't see where you're
looking right here beyond pow oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah because that wouldn't be
a capitalized saying it's super fast
guess i'm saying i'm wrong
how does the eo work
cho bam pao
i feel like that's probably
show three because you don't want to
over you don't want to be on you know
that's true
it was an interesting choice what they
did here i didn't expect that i thought
it was always gonna be just uh
stupid
i mean they made a strong choice of like
he's he's clearly shaking to the core
because that's elected yeah conflicted
and also i mean he spent that entire
outbreak bit hiding behind the nurse and
letting her do all the dirty work so
like he's obviously into her yeah and i
feel like
if i'm remembering correctly in the
previous episodes i mean he hasn't been
the most antagonistic character when it
comes to the crown prince but i felt
like he was in more opposition than he
leaves this episode are we talking about
the same person
yeah the guy who's the magistrate who's
like into the nurse and yeah and he's
got the whole gonorrhea thing yeah yeah
he was against the when was he ever
against the crown prince maybe maybe
maybe i'm uh mixing something up this is
like day one on the job firm yeah yeah
yeah but you know i mean he's he's
surrounded by a lot of people who have
that interest and yeah you know he was
in and among you know a group of them
while they were talking about such
things yeah so i just assumed by
association that he was down for that
cause more than it appears like he is an
individual is i didn't expect to
for them to develop such sympathetic
qualities for him yeah i didn't either
yeah i thought he was always to be like
just homo doofus
how did you even forget this job and i
mean it's still like that but it's yeah
more of an actual three-dimensional
character who i am sitting here going i
could hope he has some kind of arc into
a better person i mean he is arguing
already the fact that he's showing
sympathy for our young physician lady
how he was showing that while he's on
this boat with people he doesn't feel
right about it yeah you know whereas
everyone else is like yeah stay here
what's wrong with the [ __ ] peasants
why are they just complaining go hide
yeah too i mean it's interesting because
this episode was so so immediate and so
physical but you also get at least a
little context that there could be you
know uh more support coming for the
crown prince in the form of uh i forget
the character's name now but the guy
who's been in mourning and who is this
you know great warrior who helped them
you know in the wars and whatever
against japan um so you know you're
talking about noblemen mother of a
victim nope that's the wrong thing
um
but also
i mean i felt for her very very much i
mean
the way she wanted to bury her child to
respect his soul
it was good
and what's up with the queen cons i i
feel like she's having a miscarriage or
something i feel like that that baby is
not i'm gonna make it the blood on her
shoes yeah
oh i totally misread that well at first
thought it was just like blood got on
her from doing some dirty deeds could be
that too i mean no you're right why
would she be doing the dirty deeds
because she's got to protect i mean
she's got to protect that baby
feed the husband yeah if you lose the
crown at this point it's all your fault
maybe she'll have the first natural born
zombie
i
wouldn't put it past him to do something
messed up like actually would that be
gives birth to the first natural-born
zombie yeah
oh that'd be crazy and imagine that
national born zombies it's a great title
too 2024
on this day
of december
13th
around the world
180 women gave birth
to the first natural born zombies no one
could explain this
phenomenon and then as an eccentric you
know scientist billionaire going to go
round all of them up and raise them as
his own
yeah
it's umbrella academy
zombie edition yes undead umbrella
academy yeah undead academy
on debt academy
dude let's write the pitch you can't
control them no we're
useful for your cause nope because they
just go out there and circulate they're
just hungry
that's it
that's all they have on their minds
oh yeah this is great guys thanks for so
much for being here and again
encouraging us to check this out because
that episode flew by mm-hmm
[Music]
every time we start these i'm like wow
that's like 55 minutes we're going to be
here and then just like flies by yeah
so good so good gracefully so yeah no
i've never enjoyed watching such
terrible things happen to people so
consistently
not since squid game or train to bassan
way back away
all right guys hey uh subscribe we're on
patreon let's do a p
michael b i'm seeing michael b omnimedia
just hit 20 000 subscribers
yeah whatever congratulations
punk
[ __ ] just climbing up the ladder he's
covering so many tv shows right now on
his youtube page he even covered squid
game trained him a song posted is the
same day as ours and he's covering way
more tv than us but you know what
michael you're not covering kingdom boom
look i know you're working a full-time
job and you got to do all this for
youtube too but quit being a bum and
start covering kingdom as well
don't you know the secret to feeling
fulfilled is to avoid your feelings at
all times and just keep producing
content for people distract yourself
from burnout and just write you know
what they say you know what they say
if you're feeling burnt out just keep
staying on fire
and eventually you won't even feel the
flames anymore it's better to burn out
than fade away
that's not what they say that's
they just said to keep those flames
going so that you can feel as hot as
possible while you're burned down just
get used to it
now michael be empty and keep kicking
ass but i could be empty
[Music]